don't see any major changes in daily
life it's more in our minds if you know
that you have a secure country to live
and build and work
that has an impact to all of your
behavior even if you don't daily
remember it
it gives security a mind
would I say and
that is surely
it has a huge of huge importance
okay then uh gentlemen in blue and
gentleman in Bergen they die Thai and
then we will go that way
okay hey hi uh okay
it was supposed to be yeah hi this is my
name is janspin Nordstrom I'm a
journalist from tv4 in Sweden I have a
question for president Minister another
question for the both of you uh
president Minister a lot has made been
made about your personal relationship
with Vladimir Putin do you think that
that will help moderate Russia reactions
to a Finnish NATO membership or is that
a relationship of the past
and I'm also wondering negotiations with
NATO is it easier doing that with Sweden
as a duo or is it a non-issue
first to what comes to Putin yeah I
wouldn't say that that it is easier or
more difficult to moderate but
what is important that
you
you can discuss and you can discuss in a
very open but straightforward going way
in a very clear way
and that we did yesterday like like I
described
uh well
in the future
I have described that the Finnish
Russian relationship will change surely
and I'm sure writers think in a similar
way
but like I said there are
daily questions where you have
to be capable of cooperating
when the interest is common like in
security of waters in Gulf of Finland
about the question of the process when
applying tornado I don't think that the
important question is how would the
process go if Finland or Sweden would
join separately or or together I don't
think this is the important question but
the important question is how it will
affect that both countries would join
NATO how would it affect the whole
Nordic region and the security of the
whole Nordic region and I think this is
very important it is important that we
are going into the same direction it is
important that we are going at the same
Pace to the same direction I think it
will strengthen the whole Nordic region
region to secure the security of whole
Nordic so so I think this is the most
important question then I think the
process of applying the process of
negotiations with NATO and the
ratification process that would happen
smooth fast or slow
nonetheless Finland would join itself or
with together with Sweden
okay and now to the first row gentlemen
in blue and then Chang lemon with the
burgundy die on the second roll
ing Ministry
yes
so the Prime Minister and president of
Finland there taking questions from
journalists about the announcement that
Finland is formally going to apply for
membership of NATO while here with me is
Ed Arnold the former British army
officer and also a research fellow of
European security at the Royal United
Services Institute it'd be interesting
to get your reaction to that what would
the significance be then of Finland and
indeed Sweden joining NATO it's a very
significant moment in many ways in terms
of the European security architecture
what was set up post-second World War
um all of these issues use now I mean
they're changing at a rapid Pace far
quicker than they they have previously
so the significance of Finland joining
as you mentioned is actually it puts the
owners now on Sweden to make a decision
if they didn't join NATO then they'd
probably feel slightly isolated in the
nordics so it's not probably just
Finland joining it's also Sweden but
that really extends NATO's Northern
boundary so it adds an additional to
member states and in terms of Finland
they share a very long an 800 mile long
border with Russia this week ahead of
this decision you know the Prime
Minister Boris Johnson went over on
Wednesday to sign joint declarations to
make sure that
feeding Sweden and Finland are secure in
terms of applying to Nato and then the
ratification protest which will take a
couple of months ultimately until the
Article 5 NATO security guarantee uh
comes in so that was on Wednesday and
also other European nations will also
provide Provide support interesting
stuff Ed many thanks and do speak to you
again shortly